what's up man i'm with uh mtv news
i was wondering if you had any mp3s on
your computer yeah so uh how many mp3s
do you have on your computer
it's about 600 uh six or seven thousand
come again six or seven thousand
probably like 300.
for real where'd you get them from uh
truthfully most of them from napster
[Music]
the first time i heard about digital
music was through napster
and i didn't really understand what it
was but i knew i could get any song i
wanted
how many of you download music from the
internet
okay when i realized that there is an
opportunity to just download everything
we want
and not really pay for that i
i started to use it 19 year old sean
fanning developed the napster computer
program
today at byu he was treated like a rock
star
strange it's awkward i can't i'm not
used to this
he's an awesome guy and he's so young
too
[Music]
so you don't think this is stealing
not at all because you're just getting a
few songs that you find
interesting and seeing what's up there
was this
era of discovery that felt like
the virtual version of a record store i
remember
saying to myself shortly after
downloading my first mp3
i'm never going to buy music again
[Music]
don't steal the music don't steal the
music
don't steal
if people leach off the system for free
the creators of copyright will not get
compensated and the movies and music
will not get made it's as simple as that
[Music]
when it became possible for people to
get music for free
there was a lot of outcry and a lot of
concern about well
why do people think it's free well you
know why is that right if you make
something
and somebody takes it without
compensating you you're hurt by that
everyone would like to have everything
for free that's not how we work
and it's not fair it's not right
when you got a technology that gives
away
what you do free
how do you compete with free i mean
when napster hit it wasn't just an issue
for the music industry
young teenagers teenagers mind you are
coming up with ways we can get dvd
movies on our computers for free
anything that was reducible to a one or
a zero
was potentially available freely
to consumers all of this was
from a music industry executive
perspective terrifying
on the flip side for the independent
artist napster was probably a good thing
it made it so much easier to get
exposure
probably 96 97 started making my first
songs
on the computer and putting them on the
internet
then the napster came out yeah it was
pretty it was
massive you know i look at my songs on
napster and like see
see him on there like a lot you know if
a lot of search results came up
it was like a lot of people had it so
you could kind of tell like that like
wow so this stuff's really spreading you
[Music]
and drop to their know like getting
caught smuggling keys
at ease i think napster did a lot for
independent artists at that time
it was the beginning of an independent
path to find your
following such that you can sustain
yourself have a career
without having a major label contract
benefit was and is an awesome
emcee but way ahead of his time
the major labels were paying attention
to what was happening in the mp3 world
to their loss because the mp3 world was
like a minor leagues
and if somebody floats they'll rise to
the top then they could
you know zoom off to that other level
the old paradigm from the last century
only was good for that last century the
new century i look at napster as being
new radio and people are finding ways
that now you're going to have a million
artists in a million labels now
all in the record game i got the death
people hearing this blind people seeing
this
paralyzed from the neck down still
feeling it but then the flip side
if you're making a living off of music
as a musician
and suddenly your revenue streams like
cut out from under you like yeah i
totally understand
it's paralyzed
i remember lars from metallica was like
you know
he was really mad about it napster
hijacked our music without asking
they never sought our permission our
catalog of music simply became available
for free downloads on the napster system
the argument i hear a lot
that music should be free must then meet
the musicians should work for free
nobody else works for free why should
musicians
drummer lars ulrich and his bandmates
say napster is illegal and filed suit
against its creator for copyright
infringement
most artists weren't really too thrilled
with being on the other side of the kind
of the hip-hop
new young thing but lars
was frankly unafraid to get out there
if they want to steal metallica's music
instead of hiding behind their computers
in their bedrooms and dorm rooms then
just go down to towel records and grab
them off the shelves instead
when i saw lars all rich going on that
campaign
i just remember thinking that was the
lamest sink i'd ever seen
like metallica you're all millionaires
so
what are you complaining about
what's your beef with metallica then why
not let the people listen to music
as far as i'm concerned metallica
is off my best help
[Music]
there was definitely a lot of hate and a
lot of backlash
my friend definitely said yeah f
metallica i'm done
i'm only listening to nirvana now i've
removed all the metallica files from my
from my hard drive i don't want anything
to do with metallic anymore
this mattered to a lot of people napster
was like
this symbol of freedom and so
when you have guys like lars ulrich
trying to shut napster down
you're gonna have a hell of a backlash
lars's argument was the one that i
supported uh
and others in the industry did as well
but this was an
incredibly disruptive force in the music
industry no matter what side of the
argument you came down
on and the industry had to
shut all of this down
[Music]
using a pc to download music is one of
the hottest of today's computer trends
and that has the recording companies up
in arms and heading to court
at the center of their dispute is a
music sharing internet service known as
napster
the litigation against napster was
fairly monumental
they were fighting us in court
aggressively
napster's point of view is like we don't
personally share any files okay
we just facilitate connections between
users
and we're not responsible for policing
the contents of our network
pure and simple it was theft of
intellectual property and
i just can't get past that that
fundamental reality
i still get agitated uh even at this
point years later
[Music]
cnn covered the court decision live
so there was a lot of pressure you know
25 million people
were using napster every single day and
really invested in the outcome
in the end the judge ruled that it was
obvious to everyone at napster that they
knew
what was going on napster appealed that
and lost again
in a 68-page opinion the appeals court
said napster knew its users were
violating copyright infringement laws
the song swapping service this weekend
will begin blocking
access to millions of musical files on
napster
we stopped the sharing we basically took
the servers offline
over a period of time the the
obligations to the creditors just
overwhelmed the company and uh there
didn't seem to be any way to get
revenue in and so the board determined
at that point the best thing to do would
be to
go into bankruptcy the days of free
music with napster folks
are over it felt like this really
dark horrible day in san francisco
i was depressed lots of people were
depressed
technology had lost
but then of course the moles started
popping all over the place
[Music]
there are already dozens of alternatives
to napster
with names such as my napster napa gator
and cute mx we had other
file sharing services crop up that were
in many ways
more insidious there was no
centralized server that the files passed
through
and that was much more difficult to
address
even if they crack down on one program
like kazaa or something
i think there's going to be another
program coming out that in the next
week or two that's going to be doing the
same thing
the huge huge problem at the time is
that
it was very hard to tell people not to
use peer-to-peer methods
and they'll say well what should we use
and the answer was go to a record store
and buy a cd
that's not what they wanted to hear the
record companies
have to wake up and i think they will to
the fact that they're no longer in the
business of
hiring trucks and having big warehouses
and shipping
cds around people want their music via
the internet
the answer to the piracy was to give
people what they otherwise wanted in a
legitimate way
at a fair and reasonable price we needed
to have
a legitimate online music store
the labels tried in their own lame ways
to debut digital music stores of their
own which were total failures
i remember trying to use these things
and then these special players and
and it was just it was really pretty
anti-diluvian and and nobody
really signed up for these things
for the longest time there is such a
divide between silicon valley and the
music industry
you know it was just a big war
it was not in the software industry's
interest
to help the music industry they sold a
lot of computers because people wanted
to get their music and other content for
free
the music companies they said you know
you guys are all promoting
piracy and the tech guys are like oh you
guys are all a bunch of luddites you
don't understand you have to change your
business model
and the one guy who was able to bridge
that divide
was steve jobs
i've i've been back about uh eight to
ten weeks
and uh we've been working really hard
uh and what we're trying to do
uh is is not something really
highfalutin
we're trying to get back to the basics
steve jobs had been fired at apple and
then been brought back
and at the time he he apple was uh
in some ways a bit player in the
computer space
the mac products represented about three
percent market share
this company's absolutely going to turn
around as a matter of fact i think the
question now is
is is not can we turn around apple i
think that's the booby prize i think
it's
can we make apple really great again
in 2001 he introduced the ipod
there it is right there
so steve saw a great opportunity in the
music space
for apple music's been around for a long
time
you know it's a real tangible market and
i think if we can bring some value to
that market then we'll succeed
in late 2002 steve jobs called and said
that he was going to create an online
music store and i saw that as the
perfect opportunity to at least say all
right we've got something out there
we came up to cupertino and went into a
conference room and steve walks in i
don't think we
even knew that that was going to happen
but he walks in
and says i want to show you the itunes
store and then he sits there for two
hours
himself with the mouse showing how the
store would work
he was like a little kid in a candy
store absolutely
you know fascinated with this thing that
i remember thinking it's so simple
and in fact it was but that's what made
it brilliant
it worked better than anything we'd ever
seen before and it became
obvious this this was a good thing to to
go with
[Applause]
the one thing of course about the itunes
music store
he wanted every song to be a buck
steve jobs wanted to sell singles off of
every album that was on itunes
you did not want a single album on the
store that you could not break down in
singles
that had you know really serious uh
ramifications
you know for the music industry there
will be unbundling the album
[Music]
a cd is a bundle it's a bundle of songs
if you want one song you must buy the
entire package
bundles inflate the total revenue
because people are kind of forced to pay
up a bit so let's take a
canonical example which would be vanilla
ice
i would be surprised if most people can
name more than one vanilla ice song
but vanilla ice sold something like 10
million albums
on the basis of just one hit song so
150 160 million dollars in revenue
once you liberated the single from the
album that excess
income from the compact disc would go
away forever
you would only earn a small fraction of
what you previously earned
they knew this was going to hurt them
[Music]
it's to say as a music fan but it seems
like music is almost disposable now
[Music]
you would put out an album what every
six years tour
for those six years off of that one
album but now having to put out a single
and then three singles and then all of a
sudden it's just a string of singles
with no
cohesion like an album and really the
songs don't have as much meaning to you
as they did back then
the pitch that jobs made to the majors
was
we will save you it was like a siren
song
there was no choice really about anyone
who thought about it there was no choice
today we've got 200 000 tracks and
all of this music with all of these
rights
you can buy for 99 cents per song
it's called itunes itunes online music
store
the itunes music store they've really
just created
you know what we've all been waiting for
which is a purely digital music
marketplace
itunes did spectacularly well you had
that great
growth of downloads itunes recently sold
its 50
millionth song but the deal the industry
made
with apple to me was a huge mistake
the unbundling of albums meant that the
revenue that came in was significantly
diminished we were hopeful that the
physical product was hold on longer than
it did
as it turned out it didn't cd sales have
dropped almost
one quarter in just three years that's
an awful lot of lost business
buyers got very fed up with spending 18
when there's only one or two songs they
like this change with itunes made people
so
upset that people actually started
taking their products off the platform
estelle had an album that had come out
and the label found out that about 90 of
the purchases were just of one song
american boy they pulled the entire
album off the platform for three weeks
before caving in
and putting it back on
really they were desperate and they
decided what they would do
was go after the end users of the
peer-to-peer sites
the average file sharer john and jane
download
this was extremely controversial within
the record industry hillary rose and the
head of the riaa
actually resigned in protest i didn't
want us to go against individuals
even though they were the source of a
huge amount of illegal activity
i felt like ultimately they were still
music fans
but essentially i was kind of overruled
my last day at the raa was the day
before the
litigation against individuals started
[Music]
yesterday the music industry took
another step for the first time going
after people downloading and swapping
music online we want people to stop
engaging in the theft of music
so that people can go on making it
i don't remember if i got it via letter
or email
but i basically got what looked like a
scam
from the riaa saying you owe us for
having downloaded music i honestly
ignored it because i didn't care
and uh i got
they sent another letter saying i could
be sued for up to thirty thousand
dollars
per song of which there were thousands
i didn't have that much money
i don't think anyone did i wasn't ever
really worried about
getting fined for downloading mp3s
mainly because i was using my mom's
computer
and i was kind of so i was like oh my
mom's going to get fined not me
like you can't take a 13 year old's
income when he doesn't have any income
they filed something like 17 000
lawsuits
but rather than going after the big
infringers they ended up
suing children and grandmothers and
people who were dead
and you know moms bonnie bassett was
shocked to be slapped with a lawsuit for
the hundreds of songs her teens
downloaded off the internet
for free my kids go to catholic school
we
bring we brought them up right no one in
our family has been arrested i mean we
don't
we don't steal we don't steal it's just
ridiculous
it was absurd it was absurd i'm not
downloading
anything ever again i mean not even
screensavers
almost everybody was forced to settle
often for a relatively small amount of
money like three or four thousand
dollars
but in the end this just made people
hate them
it didn't create a deterrent effect it
just made them loathed
you know i've been an avid record
collector for over 40 years right i've
got nearly 10
000 records you turned a music fan
into an enemy in fact more people
probably went to piracy as a result of
this than anything else
[Music]
i ended up having to pay like i think
close to a thousand dollars to the riaa
but in the end i ended up recouping my
losses by downloading
overtime and doubling down
between the piracy and the unbundling
the industry recognized that it was on a
decline
and over the course of you know
15 years shrank significantly
industry revenue i think in 99 was
worldwide 34 billion
and it fell to something like 16 billion
the industry was just destroyed
annihilated
a simple dynamic in business when
an industry is under threat you
consolidate
which is a fancier word for cutting
costs
you put two big music enterprises
together you can eliminate a whole bunch
of jobs
i'm currently standing in front of what
used to be the verge of megastore union
square
closed in june of 2009 and is now
a dwayne reed and a citibank
[Music]
this building formerly used to be tower
records
it was the first tower records in new
york
that window right there where the light
is that floor i worked on
it was the um od section
cd sales were dipping since i think like
2000 2001
that's where the decline really kicked
in i can't even remember the last time i
physically went and bought a cd
when 2006 happened was all over for me
that was the end of it there wasn't much
i could do
tower records may be toppling the music
chain is preparing to file for
bankruptcy next week
when tower was brought out a lot of us
the employees that worked there
fell into like a depression we're like
wow this this is
it the tower is going to be gone for
good
how do i feel about it crappy
you